this video is sponsored by brilliant.org
these are black lion tamarinds from the
Atlantic rainforest of Brazil and they
are on the verge of Extinction but some
people are fighting to change that lots
of people follow this YouTube channel
because of the Vlogs I made during my
PhD in atmospheric physics at the
University of Exeter unfortunately
however I had to graduate at some point
and that necessarily meant the end of my
videos showing what doing a PhD was like
however there are lots of people out
there doing interesting PhD projects and
so in this video series I'm spending a
few days with a new researcher each
episode showing you what that life is
like learning a bit about them and
learning about the topic of their thesis
this time is rather different normally
in this series I go somewhere and talk
to someone in the middle of their PHD
but this time I'm speaking to Lisa who
is hoping to start her project soon the
reason I'm speaking to Lisa is because
last summer I was on the island of
Jersey speaking at the literary Festival
about my book firmament and I had an
afternoon spare so I went to maybe my
favorite place in the entire world World
Jersey Zoo now if I asked you to think
of a zoo you'd probably think of a place
with lions and elephants that people go
to with their kids to gawk at the
animals and maybe throw peanuts Jersey
zoo is very different to that and a lot
of that comes down to its founder so
Charles amazing man
um so I'm sure most people know a lot
about this history because he's been on
TV both in person and in fiction so just
someone who was really fascinated by the
natural world from childhood grew up to
become a collector of animals for zoos
and through that became very much aware
of the problems that are facing animals
and plants worldwide because of human
behavior and so he then developed his
vision for a zoo that that supported
conservation as its main goal rather
than a super entertaining people as he
documented in a famous series of books
Gerald Durrell saw species disappearing
around the world over his lifetime but
unfortunately the number of species at
risk of Extinction has only increased
over time currently 28 of all species
assessed by the iucn are threatened with
Extinction though that percentage varies
hugely depending on what class of plant
or animal you're looking at why are so
many species disappearing unfortunately
because of us unfortunately most of them
are human impacts on their environments
the big one is climate change and that's
becoming more and more obvious in areas
of the world in which we work and in
other areas as well it's affecting their
habitat it's affecting the resources
that are available to them forests are
being cut for fuel to clear land from
agriculture or for a livestock farming
and where we're working in Madagascar
and like a lot of the marshes are being
cleared for fishing the follow-on
impacts of things like that are things
like soil erosion we're having impacts
in terms of the noise that we make and
the pollution that we cause all these
things are having huge impacts there are
very few species that are completely
unaffected by human activity fortunately
not all human impacts on Wildlife are
negative and some humans like Gerald
Durrell and like Elena are working to
prevent species from going extinct this
is something done in the wild what you
probably think of when you think of
conservation things like protecting
gorilla or Rhino reserves but it's also
done in captive populations through
research our chief scientist Carl Jones
likes to call it the interface between
the world and captivity I feel now that
that's just it's becoming more and more
relevant simply because the human
impacts now is so widespread for so many
species that we are going to be managing
them in the world as well as as we are
in captivity Daryl engages in two kinds
of activities with species such as the
tamarinds firstly building up a breeding
population in captivity a safety net in
case something goes wrong in the wild
and informing conservation activities in
situ in this case meaning in Brazil with
the captive population and this is where
Lisa comes in so I'm Lisa and I am a zoo
research intern so I've been working
here since February of this year so I'm
working on the black line Tamarin Nest
box project I did my Master's research
here last year so this is like testing
up to my PhD that will hopefully start
next year my undergraduate was in
conservation biology it was quite a nice
and Broad course that covered a lot of
different aspects of whether you were
doing lab work looking at different
genetic aspects or whether it was field
work we did a couple of field trips and
then I did my masters at Nottingham
which was endangered species recovery
and conservation genetics is not
necessarily my ballpark so looking at
Behavioral Studies and what you need to
reintroduce animals into the wild and
then I came here to do my thesis
research and obviously fell in love with
working with the Blackline tamarinds and
decided that that was you know it for me
so I started working with them Zoo
research is a big part of what they do
at Daryl so I was really Keen to
continue to work with them so they gave
me the opportunity to come back this
year bits of study now to set me up for
hopefully my PhD next year so black lion
tamoons are endangered and they're a
species of primates so a small monkey
that comes from South America as they're
only found in Brazil and they're found
in the Atlantic rainforest area of
Brazil there are four different species
of and tamarinds it's a group called the
calatrick kids it's all the little ones
that you'll see in zoos when you go
around the little cute ones so there's
1600 approximately left in the wild
they're split among different Forest
fragments the majority of them are in a
forest called moradablo State Park the
rest of them are kind of separated out
far enough away that they can't disperse
and and cross between the fragments
easily because people have cut all the
trees down between them it started to
fragment the populations the genetics
starting to get a little bit more
concentrated in those areas and not
being able to cross between the
fragments each family group will have a
territory and so when they're Offspring
and needing to leave to go find their
own mates there may not be anywhere to
go former territory if The Offspring try
to leave the fragmented Forest areas
then they might get one over on roads
they might get predated basically it's
it's not a good outcome for them and so
they've kind of they reach a carrying
capacity and they can't get any they
can't continue to expand the population
okay so this is the bit I've been really
looking forward to
now we're going in
to try and overcome the problem of
forest fragmentation conservationists in
Brazil have been planting tree corridors
narrow strips of trees that connect the
forest fragments and allow Tamarind
populations to safely travel and
intermingle this sounds like an ideal
solution but a quirk of the tamarind's
behavior has made these corridors less
successful than expected so one of the
problems for the Blackline taverns is
that they sleep in older trees that have
tree holes because they've hollowed out
when they get older they are building
lovely new tree corridors but they're
really young trees so to make the
corridors functional for them they'd
need nest boxes so they have safe sleep
sites and they have those areas that
they want to use so we're looking at not
only how to put different modifications
in the boxes like a tunnel because that
makes it harder for predators to
actually reach in and grab tamarinds at
night which is one of the big problems
looking at different materials that we
can use some of the problems of the nest
boxes they've already trialled some out
there with our partners the wooden boxes
Africanized bees are starting to
colonize them so this is making them
really humid obviously the tamarinds
aren't going to go anywhere near them
when they've got bees in them the new
material we're using which is Echo plays
a recycled compressed plastic we've
tested it on bees here and they really
struggle to build up structures on the
surface of it which obviously they're
probably quite different to the bees
you'll find out in Brazil but it's a
nice start to be able to see that
different materials might be more
suitable than the plywood that they're
using at the minute I should probably be
doing something other than just kind of
Greening like an idiot and being
surrounded by tamarinds but this is it's
a little bit overwhelming to be
surrounded it all started
absolutely enchanting monkeys
but I'm sure there are lots of you
watching who are thinking these are cute
monkeys and everything but why should I
care if one species of animal goes
extinct in Brazil the key thing to try
and remember is that no species lives in
isolation all species have a role to
play in that web of relationships that
is an ecosystem if you lose one small
monkey that might not look too serious
but that monkey will probably disperse
the seeds of several plants it will be
food for some of the other animals that
are there it has a role to play in in
preying on insects and so on and so if
we start thinking that it's okay to lose
one what we end up with is a
non-functioning system and that of
course is terrible in itself but it has
huge implications for human beings you
know it affects water it affects
temperature it affects you know food
availability effects all these things
that we depend on to survive we're
tearing our our life support system
apart and even one tiny little element
of it could be crucial a lot of people
look at animals as separate to us I
think it's our responsibility to make
sure that we can live in harmony with
them and not separate and I think
dedicating my life to helping them live
how they should live without our
disturbance is the best thing I could do
so hopefully you agree then that
conservation is important but understand
that it isn't just done in the wild it's
also done in captivity although quite
how much of its distinction there is
between those two is kind of Up For
Debate and when it's performed in
captivity it's performed as any other
kind of scientific research is Lisa's
work that will go towards her PhD and
the work done at Daryl in general
informs and will inform how conservation
is done in the wild and may determine
whether this species of monkeys survives
or not and there is so much more to
learn there's lots of things that we
want to look at or that I would like to
look at in terms of behavior so being
able to follow them out in Brazil and be
able to monitor their behavior do
personality assessments and see what
groupings they have out there because
there's also research that shows there's
a link between cortisol levels in
tamarinds and their susceptibility to
diseases and which has been a real big
problem for some tamarins out there
they've been decimated by yellow fever
it's important to understand if you can
look at it in terms of a behavior route
whether that would then help inform
conservation strategies without people
doing research phds Masters whatever it
is you don't end up learning all these
new things I think it's very easy for
people in so many aspects of life to say
we think we know everything but you have
to accept that you never will and it's
always constant learning and I think
that that's why it's so important for
people to still be involved to stay
interested and keep working on things
because the more we learn the more we
can do to improve as we've seen in this
series research takes many forms
sometimes with immediate impacts as in
this case and sometimes with expected
impacts far in the future and it can be
performed in dedicated facilities in
abstract in practice or in the blurry
region between theory and practice it's
sometimes a battle to convince people
that zoos do have this role in providing
the evidence for conservation strategies
and methods and developing those
techniques and I think I've been so
happy with our recent work particularly
Lisa's studies on the list boxes because
I think that that's such a clear example
of what a zoo can do to directly
influence the conservation of a species
and a habitat I think trying to do that
more is my aim and I'm hoping that Susan
general which talk a lot about
conservation nowadays can start putting
that into practice themselves
science is a process to quote Massive
Attack it's a doing word it's a process
performed in labs and universities but
also in the wild and as we've seen in
zoos but you don't have to be a
scientist in order to benefit from
understanding the scientific process if
you work in a job or you would like to
work in a job that uses critical
thinking maths or really any kind of
analysis then by studying Concepts in
science you can improve your
problem-solving skills for example let's
say you shuffle a deck of 30 cards
labeled 1 to 30 and draw a card what's
the probability that the number on your
card is greater than 25 or less than 10.
now if you immediately found yourself
drawn to working out the answer to this
question then you're going to love
brilliant.org who have kindly sponsored
this video this is an example problem
from the course on probability by
brilliant who offer interactive
beautifully Illustrated courses on
subjects in science maths and computer
science at a variety of levels from
introductory such as mathematical
fundamentals to intermediate such as
Vector calculus and while they have
thousands of lessons more are added
every month this isn't your traditional
educational resource brilliant doesn't
teach you to memorize formulas or
equations but instead to improve your
scientific intuition making you a better
Problem Solver and all this in
bite-sized lessons that you can easily
fit in gaps in your day by learning on
your computer phone or tablet to try
everything brilliant has to offer free
for a full 30 days visit brilliant.org
Simon Clark Linked In the description
and the first 200 of you to do so will
get 20 off brilliant's annual premium
subscription that's brilliant.org Simon
Clark with thanks again to brilliant for
sponsoring this video and for being as
always brilliant
thank you so much for watching if you
would like to support Daryl's work
saving species from going extinct then
what you can do is donate donate donate
to Daryl at their website link is down
there in the description and also if
you're visiting Jersey go visit the zoo
thanks to Lisa Rachel and aluned for
being so generous with their time and
for allowing me to meet the tamarinds in
person and Banks must also go to these
lovely people on screen right now who
are my executive producers over on
patreon.com forward slash simonox vids
if you would like to support the channel
then you can do so there that just leads
me to say thank you again for watching
if you'd like to watch something else
then here's some recommendations if you
enjoyed this video please do pop it a
like and I'll see you in the next one